hello folks welcome to rational science
i hope everybody can hear me and see me
okay today
if not
please let me know okay
i hope uh everything's okay
uh the other day i had a little problem
and i changed computers
and that didn't solve the problem i had
a worse problem with my uh
backup computer
and i tried a third computer
and
that one had problems the obs
and my mouse did not seem to agree the
mouse was working a little
slower than what it was supposed to i
got to figure out what's going on there
because it's a brand new mouse
yeah thank you
and uh
the the mouse
was working slow with respect to the obs
if anyone knows what could cause that
because these are brand new equipment so
i have no idea why that's not working
very well and guess what i had to return
to my old computer this is my old
computer and the new ones are still
working the problem i've got with this
computer is that the keys four seven and
nine are not working
they're dead they got more arthritis
than i do
and so uh you know i can't use those
three keys i can't use the keypad either
the number pad
and so i got to send it out for repair
or whatever i don't even know if they
can repair that maybe it's
it's the end of this computer as well
but at least i can transmit
okay
anyways what do we do here well we do a
little bit of extinction we do a little
bit of physics and extinction is a
branch of physics paleontology is a
branch of physics
uh
what i typically do with the
with extinction is look at the
news the headlines especially find out
what's going on uh what's going on out
there in the world
and
[Music]
what can i say you know i see two hot
spots right now i don't know if they'll
continue but very likely they will one
is ukraine
uh where the united states meets russia
and the other one is taiwan where the
united states meets china
and so those are spots that might take
us to world war three
uh will there be a war
or will these people be able to avoid it
so uh you know that's one issue the
other one is if there is a war
will it be the war that ends all wars
you know like
the last war you know what i mean
and so a couple people had uh questions
on that or comments they said the
following says
people of the world are protesting and
waking up
okay we are in need of world war three
okay uh
and he continues says evil rules the
world because the world is protesting
against the oppression
world war three will be needed to
confine back into a state of dependency
protest all you want world war three is
coming
is world war iii desirable will it be uh
well we killed a few billion people and
then we you know we start all over again
is that the way it works or will it be
like uh einstein said you know uh world
war four will be fought with sticks and
stones
is world war iii desirable will it end
at conventional weapons
will they um
continue with uh nuclear weapons
until
there's nothing left
you know it's uh the way i look at it's
uh lose-lose situation no matter what if
there is not a war we're going to fall
because the global economy is going to
fall to pieces
that's one side if we do have a war
you're destroying the global economy as
well even if someone wins
you know i don't know what that means
it's like going to be a pyrrhic victory
someone wins what do you end up with
well you end up with a destroyed economy
global economy okay
and so
if there is a world war three even if we
don't die by military means we will buy
die by economic means
uh immediately right after that
okay so that's the way i see it no i
don't think it's desirable to have a
world war three and the more we can
postpone it
uh the better okay that's the way i look
at it at least until i'm dead then you
guys can go ahead and have the war
if you want to continue having war no
problem and continuing with that so this
fellow says world war three is happening
right now uh-huh we're already i didn't
know there was a war going on okay but
he says
right in front of our faces hidden in
plain sight silent weapons for quite
quiet wars such as frequencies we need
to respond in a passive resistance way
get rid of your television to start
there i agree you know the best way to
solve all these problems is you know
turn your tv off
you know you don't hear about the news
you don't have to worry about it
especially stuff that's not in your
local area that doesn't affect you i
mean
if you're in i don't know in a little
town in kansas
are you concerned that the israelis and
palestinians are fighting out there i
mean it's like who cares it's their
problem not your problem right
and and you can say that about almost
any hot spot on the planet ukraine
taiwan whatever who cares it's their
problem
and uh another fella answers passive
resistance will not work
our only hope that police and army rebel
[Laughter]
uh
who controls the police and the army i i
wonder about that you know
but no uh the way i look at it when the
global economy collapses and that's a
when not an if
when the global economy collapses what
will happen at that point
um
uh you know
there won't be any money
to pay
the armies the police and even if you
did have money to pay them like you can
create money anyways bitcoin whatever
you want to pay them with
it it won't have any value so there's no
way to control
the troops once money has no value in
fact that happened to a great extent in
russia in uh
1917. you know the armies rebelled uh
the the military the soldiers they
rebelled they mutinied
and
how are you going to stop that it's like
all these people just
going out there doing their thing
robbing stores uh
you know stealing grain because they
were hungry feeding their families
you can't stop that
you know it's massive
and you know you better be prepared for
something like that when the economy is
no more that's the way i look at it
anyways
okay uh
in another matter pal says i made a
response video to your theory on the
causes of homosexuality
and i went there and looked at that
video and felt essentially these are the
main points i guess you could say
homosexuality doesn't exist theories
don't explain behavior okay homosexuals
can change
so he thinks it's uh
kind of like a learned thing okay
animals are not homosexual
and a man cannot have part of his brain
in female form in other words
you're either a man or a woman you can't
have a brain
a female brain in a man's body so
something like that or parts of your
brain or whatever
i don't know uh all i can tell you is
that
um
i don't make these i don't work off of
these assumptions i work out of the
opposite okay almost in every instance
there
and here let me show you one that's
probably the most important there which
is that last one
okay here it is
okay and this fella is dick swab
and he studied uh what is called a
sexually dimorphic nucleus this is what
he writes in one of his papers he wrote
several papers and he's not the only one
okay and what you have is it says he
says the following says in a sample of
brains of homosexual men we did find
that an area of the hypothalamus called
the sub whatever scn contains twice as
many cells as the scn of a heterosexual
group
another nucleus is more than twice as
large in heterosexuals as in homosexual
men
whereas alan and gorski found that the
interior commissure was larger in
homosexual men than in heterosexual men
or women
so
all i can say is yeah they have found
differences uh people in not only this
group dick swabs group but other people
have found who do research they claim to
have found differences in the
structure
certain parts of the brain which are
either smaller or greater
in females and males there are
differences and they found the same
differences
between men and women as they found
between heterosexuals and homosexuals
so you know i operate out of those
assumptions by the way they found those
same differences in sheep remember uh
sheep about 10 percent of sheep are
coming out homosexual
and they determine that because they
take one of these uh male [ __ ] sheeps
and they have like 10
sheep in a stall you know with their
butts facing outwards
and
the guy always comes and you know mounts
a male not a female
and so they they figured out that
approximately 10
of of sheep are gay
and when they looked at the uh
brains of these animals
you know they killed them i guess or
they died and then they cut
their you know they looked at their
brains they found the same type of
differences there's a sexual dimorphism
between uh heterosexual and gay sheep
and i'm sure if you do that with lions
lions mountain lions also as well you
see that there and i'm sure there are
other animals that have homosexuality i
don't think uh it's correct to assume
that homosexuality doesn't exist and it
doesn't exist among animals i think both
of those are wrong assumptions at least
those are not the assumptions i make
okay when i analyze these uh issues
okay and uh here talking about
dimorphism here we have uh another issue
that i brought up and asked whether
males and females should have unisex
sports should there be no differences
between females and males should they
all compete against each other
in all categories uh boxing judo karate
whatever you want okay
and a fella says for dimorphism to catch
up there needs to be an evolutionary
pressure but currently females still
prefer taller men in other words there
is no uh evolutionary pressure for women
to come up to the sp to the height and
strength of men because they prefer
apparently and according to
stronger men or you know a taller men
etc
in most mammal species individuals are
attracted by genetic diversity
phenome
pheromones attract only dissimilar
individuals offspring will then have a
better immune system
will they will they have an immune
system a better immune system because of
uh of these pheromones
and then women live longer because they
have better immune system they have more
white blood cells than men okay i don't
know if that's true maybe it is
the need to protect the embryo during a
pregnancy
well all i can say uh i'm not telling
i'm asking a question okay all i'm doing
here is asking a question will women
given enough time given another thousand
years
will they come up to speed uh with men
in others will there be no sexual
dimorphism in the sense that men are
stronger taller faster etc will will
they be the same you know or even women
surpass them will there be a world
champion uh
female boxer for example heavyweight or
whatever
uh i'm asking i'm not i'm not
speculating i'm asking the question only
okay and yeah all i can say is uh i
don't know the other question related to
that is
does um
estrogen have anything to do with that
does testosterone have anything to do
with that is it that we are bigger
stronger men you know
because we have testosterone is that the
reason or is there something else going
on
because you know you have women
who
do not shoot up or anything and they are
strong they are big by nature and uh and
i'm sure they have a lot of estrogen in
them
okay so
you know
it's something to ponder whether
estrogen and testosterone
have anything really to do with strength
speed and you know all those good things
that us men enjoy
today
maybe not tomorrow
okay so food for thought
okay let's get on with the subject
matter with physics today
and what we're going to be looking at is
force
and a related subject to force is mass
okay
so where do we start well whenever you
don't know where to start you go back in
time
and you start with the greeks
when you start with the greece you
probably start with a guy who did the
most
uh analysis of all these subject
subjects from physics right that was
aristotle
and just to clarify aristotle probably
did not write everything he's credited
with
remember he was a macedonian
and he was alexander the great's tutor
okay
he uh he educated alexander the great so
when alex became the boss
um
uh aristotle was sent to athens or he
went there i think he was sent there and
a lot of athenians considered uh
aristotle spy
like you know this guy's gonna be
telling alex something about us
you know and so
they they were very reserved with
aristotle but aristotle found his school
and a lot of the athenian rich kids
right they went to that school
and they wrote took notes when aristotle
gave his classes his lectures and so
i think that a lot of what came out of
the uh
aristotle school were simply stuff that
his students also wrote you know so i
think it's collection
of greek thought you could say in those
days
so i don't think it's like aristotle had
all this time in the world to just sit
down and write he was giving lectures he
was talking he was
doing some politics out there as well
and i think a lot of what we have today
which is credited to aristotle really
comes from his students okay
uh just uh something again you know food
for thought
okay anyways we go to aristotle what did
he have to say
um
and for this we have to start with uh
you know with um
uh
again what aristotle said about force
and mass or his notions about motion
okay
and here we have it he's uh this is out
of his book uh
physics his book i think
or his student's book says all movement
is either compulsory or according to
nature
and if there is compulsory movement
there must also be natural for
compulsory movement is contrary to
nature
okay so he had this notion that there's
these different kinds of movements one
where it's natural movement and the
other one compulsory something moves
something else okay
so this was uh aries uh notion of this
and uh
he had this notion that a lot of people
a lot of generations later criticized
about him which is his notion of that
if you drop two stones
the heavier one will fall faster
and these are notes that you get from
his book that you can see where his
train of thought goes he says everything
that is in motion must be moved by
something
in other words he thought that
uh
you required a force to constantly move
something okay
and then he says if a given force move a
given way a certain distance in a
certain time and half the distance in
half the time
okay
half the motive power will move half the
weight the same distance in the same
time
this was his reasoning
and he would criticize a lot for that
for for this train of thought by later
generations because they said
i don't think that's true
okay
and here let me give you another one uh
related to that one it goes like this
says for let b
well let's go simply with a circled one
there it says then air is twice as thin
the body will traverse b in twice the
time that it does d and the time g will
be twice the time e
and always by so much as the medium is
more incorporeal and less resistant and
more easily divided the faster will be
the movement
okay so he had these notions about
something that moves twice as fast as
something else and that was related to
the weight and to the force applied and
he was studying motion or trying to
analyze motion in these terms okay so
this is this is more or less his train
of thought and again he was criticized
quite a bit by later generations who
said ah you know the problem with you
harry
you did not do any experiments
see if you would have done an experiment
and observed you would you wouldn't have
said such nonsense okay
and that's where they introduced
especially in the 17th century and
onwards uh that you need experiments and
you need to measure
you need to come up with an equation
in order to say things
like you know in order to not make these
big blunders
and the answer is no you don't need
measurement you do not need equations
and you do not need to do experiments
what you need in science is to explain
at home you can do all the experiments
you want you can measure all you want
you can calculate anything you want
bring all the equations you want so far
you have a description so far you have
nothing but a description science is not
about describing science is about
explaining when you come to the
conference we want an explanation of the
mechanism
not a description
and so the fact that you do an
experiment the fact that they overruled
aristotle and said ah you didn't do an
experiment and because of that you did
not observe if you would have observed
if you would have measured you would
have calculated you would have had the
equation then you could have said
something a little more sound
and yeah that's only for descriptions
so far you have nothing more than a
description okay science explanation
not descriptions
okay um
here we have galileo who comes in the
17th century and he's made
famous because people say oh you know
what galileo did he proved aristotle
wrong
he proved aristotle wrong okay how did
he brew him wrong well he dropped two
balls from the tower pisa right in italy
and he found out that they both fall at
the same time even though one was
heavier than the other
okay and here is uh more or less
galileo's
uh argument on that that's from his book
okay
and uh he says the following says he
remembers a dialogue it was common to
make books in in those terms in those
days and he's got salviati speaking he
says aristotle says that an armball of
100 pounds falling from a height of 100
cubits reaches the ground before a one
pound ball that has fallen a single
cubit i said that i say that they arrive
at the same time okay
and he says aristotle declares that
bodies of different weights in the same
medium travel uh with speeds which are
proportional to their weights
okay
and then he says you will have to show
that a stone of 20 pounds moves 10 times
as rapidly as one of two but i claim
that this is false and that if they fall
from a height of 50 or 100 cubits they
will reach the earth at the same moment
okay this was his argument and this is
more or less what uh galileo had in mind
okay here you see it give me a second
here okay there it goes there's a good
old galileo there
and
he's allegedly went to the tower pisa
okay
drop the stones he shows that it's uh
you know they
fall at different speeds at different
levels
and did galileo ever perform this
experiment that's the question we have
okay
and all i can say is uh
you know i think it's apocryphal i think
he he did not
uh ever perform that experiment
especially from tower pisa i think uh he
just rolled stones uh rope balls
on incline planes and he studied that
because he was able to
measure them with clocks okay and so he
had different incline planes he had
different weights uh balls of different
weights and he just rolled them and
figured out you know measured and
found out that they don't
they don't match what aristotle said
that was essentially his his idea
but the question is the first question
we have to answer is because a lot of
people just repeat that and say oh
galileo he was such a saint
did galileo
was galileo is he the guy who
discovered this
is he the guy
who went to the tower piece and two
threw two balls from there or you know
two stones or whatever is he the guy who
did all this
or the first guy
and so let's first settle that because
if you repeat that all you're doing is
making a fool of yourself okay means you
didn't do a minimum of research okay so
let's get that out of the way first of
all okay here we have a fellow who uh
did it in 1586.
remember
galileo
started doing these experiments the
original experiments he did them around
1604
and he writes his book in 1638 after the
catholic church
put him under house arrest
you know he wasn't allowed to publish
things related to god and how the
uh planets move
but he was able to do his experiments on
mass again he took up his old
uh
experiments from 1604 he took him up
again close to 1638 he started doing
these experiments again and then he
writes his book
1638. here's 1586
50 years earlier okay this is uh mr
steven he's dutch
and he says the following this he writes
in his book the elements of the art of
wayne
okay he says the experience against
aristotle is the following let us take
as the very learned mr cornett's the
groot
most industrious investigator of the
secrets of nature and myself have done
two spheres of lead the one ten times
larger and heavier than the other and
drop them together from a height of 30
feet onto a board or something on which
they give a perceptible sound
then it will be found that the lighter
will not be 10 times longer on its way
than the heavier but that they fall
together onto the board uh so
simultaneously that their sounds seem to
be one and the same rap
okay that's 1586
was mr7 the first one
well for this we have to go back uh ten
years and we find out uh we find this
fellow his name is giuseppe
giuseppe moletti okay
and uh he already in his book uh this is
in 1576 10 years earlier
uh when uh galileo was still in in high
school i guess
and he says the same he says more or
less he said let fall from the top of a
tall tower two balls
one or twenty pounds of lead the other
one pound okay and then he says at the
end he says they touch the earth or
ground at the same moment in time
now whether molete did this or not i
can't tell you what i can tell you for a
fact is the following
molete was
professor at the university of padua
in italy
when he retired
galileo took his job
they knew each other they were friends
uh molete came before galileo
he wrote books before galileo
and he was galileo's teacher
so what do you think galileo got this
two stone deal this two-ball steal
a deal
he probably got it from moletti
more than likely now where did moletti
get was he the first guy did he get it
from steven or did stephen get it from
maletti well we go back in time and this
is important so that you don't make a
fool of yourself every time you say oh
galileo proved uh let's find out okay
here we have this uh fellow his name is
uh cardano
and uh he wrote this book in 1550 where
he says the same thing when he analyzed
already the weights of things falling
okay
was he the first guy
you can see what the subject matter of
his book
a lot to do with religion but he did try
to analyze you know uh the nature of
things okay in fact uh he says he calls
his book the subtlety of things
okay was he the first guy well let's
find out here we have a few years
earlier like 13 years
earlier this is nicola tartaglia he
writes a book in 1537 where he drops uh
objects from a window all the way to the
bottom he already had determined that
you know that objects do not uh fall at
the same time
that i mean at different times as
galileo had said
and you say okay so i guess our tiger
gets the nobel prize he was the first
guy well uh someone preceded him by at
least a thousand years okay and here's
uh
we have mr um
john philoponus okay let me get back in
here
and uh he said already in the uh sixth
century okay he says the following he
says um
for if you let fall from the same height
two weights okay
one many times heavier than the other
you will see that the ratio of the times
required for the motion does not depend
on the weights but that the difference
in time is very small
so he did not measure he could not come
up with an equation he could not tell
you how fast or slow because they didn't
have you know whether they have water
clocks in those
you know they didn't have accurate
clocks so he wouldn't be able to tell
you exactly how it how uh
they felt but what he could tell you is
that look aristotle is wrong you know uh
something that weighs 10 times as much
as another one doesn't fall 10 times as
fast
okay so this has been going on for years
but everybody gives credit to galileo
and galileo took a lot of these things
from someone else why did galileo become
famous
for two reasons maybe you could say
three when he did experiments
carefully carefully constructed
experiments then he measured with a
clock
and third it was newton who made galileo
famous newton was the guy who said oh
galileo he came up with this and he
built on what galileo had already you
know set the foundations for
okay that's why galileo's
famous today
did newton read steven
did he uh read tartaglia he probably
didn't even know that these guys existed
or even wrote books
i don't know
knew any of these other fellows
otherwise he wouldn't have credited uh
galileo was so much it's like you know
you built on the
nearest guy to you uh galley little died
on the year that newton was born
and so you know it's like uh this is a
book that's available to him that's what
he uses a foundation for his theory but
he didn't go through history to find out
you know everybody
who came up with the uh two-ball thing
and
and who talked about mass and force and
so on but you know think about something
else uh
the arabs in the 10th and 11th century
you know they were in in their golden
age
and they were doing a lot of experiments
uh optics especially and they probably
figured a lot of these things out as
well i mean i don't have access to all
these arab books but i'm sure if we go
through their their books we're going to
find a lot of information regarding
force and mass as well
in those books
i'm sure they discovered that aristotle
wasn't quite right
in his mind okay
okay so here's just the summary okay of
uh all the people who preceded galileo
okay uh not all of them but there you
see some names you see uh philoponis uh
tartaglia
another father benedetti all these guys
maletti
stephen all these people preceded
galileo in the two stone
uh or two ball uh experiment okay
they probably didn't have accurate
clocks to measure but they pretty much
realized that you know there
uh there is no difference or very little
difference at best if you two through
two stones with different weights okay
to the ground
okay
um but one thing that uh galileo did was
um he enunciated essentially
newton's um
first law you know that one's credited
to newton
did newton come up with that one you
know and here uh
here you see what i'm talking about
aristotle uh said that an object
requires continual force to keep it
moving galileo said an object moves
forever unless you know something kind
of retains it and i'm sure aristotle
figure that out as well okay but the
issue is uh
look at how galileo has it in his mind
he says an object continues moving a
straight line unless a force acts upon
it
okay that's that's his notion what do we
get from newton well we get the same
thing it's known as newton's uh
uh first law of motion okay
and here you see it okay his first law
of notion of motion
and
already you have people like pierre
gascendy who one year before newton was
born 1641 already wrote about it okay
and newton just rephrased that and he
gets the credit for it as the first law
of motion oh newton came up with it no
he did not come up with it but newton
rephrased and he says everybody
perseveres in its state of being at rest
or a move or of moving uniformly uh
straight forward except insofar as it is
compelled to change in its state by
forces impressed
so newton just rephrased what all these
people already had in mind yeah it's not
like newton invented the first law of
motion but he's given credit for it just
like galileo has given credit for the
the two ball experiment okay
so you got to keep in mind that unless
you do a little bit of research on some
of these issues you're giving credit to
the wrong guy and all you're doing is
repeating but they taught you in school
you know you got to be careful with that
because there is information out there
where you can show that these people
were not the originators of those
theories you know if you leave it up to
uh the mathematical physicists they will
tell you the only two people that it
existed that were alive in the 17th
century were galileo and newton
that's not true there were a lot of
people there in those days and a lot of
mathematicians
who were very well versed in mathematics
and so on okay so
and they also you know provided theories
and so on there was a lot of discussion
uh newton wrote to leibniz and vice
versa a mathematician in germany
you know these guys were had
correspondence between them they
exchanged ideas not through the internet
but you know it was by mule
but they they did exchange information
okay so
you know who can be credited with what
you know that's up for grabs sometimes
all you can do is go off the record and
uh not by you know hearsay you know word
of mouth
so how about newton's second law okay
second law of motion force equals mass
times acceleration did newton come up
with that well all i can tell you here
is that newton did not come up with this
uh notion let me put over here of mass
times acceleration force equals mass
times acceleration you won't find it in
his book it's not in there okay what
newton said essentially a change in
motion is proportional to the motive
force impressed and takes place along
the straight line in which that force is
impressed
and from that the french
men who got a hold of his book say ah
force equals mass times acceleration it
wasn't newton who came up with that
equation but that's essentially what he
insinuated and that's what we learned
today we say oh newton's second law okay
how about gravity
i mean newton's famous for gravity right
let's find out what newton uh proposed
on gravity and here you see it
okay
uh uh this is what he wrote in priscipia
two places uh in section 12 and section
13. uh he essentially was doing theorems
he was trying to prove certain things
okay so he says i say that a corpuscle
put in a place outside the surface of
the sphere is attracted to the center of
the sphere by a force inversely
proportional to the square of its
distance from the same center
and then because he that was for
spherical bodies he said something
similar for non-spherical bodies he says
if the attraction of a body by another
shall be far greater when it is
attracted in contact then then when the
bodies may be separated by the smallest
distance from each other then the forces
of the tracking particles in the distant
parts of the attracting body decrease in
a ratio greater than the square of the
distances from the particles
so he essentially came up with this uh
square of the distance rule okay
but it turns out that uh you have his
countryman robert hook
and
when newton writes his book principia
robert hook accused them of plagiarizing
uh
hooks
hooks ideas
because hook was in charge of the royal
society and he wrote many letters back
and forth with newton
and he says he proposed to newton the
square of the distance
and he maintained that position until
the end of his life
and newton all said you know i never
credited hook for that specific thing
because hook did not come up with an
equation
he had no
um
he did not prove it
he just guessed at it he had a hunch
that it was true whereas newton was able
to show in his book
um
that it was true you know that that was
uh that it was exactly the case and so
it was a difference between one guy
believing it and the other guy proving
it so so to speak and so newton says you
know i'm not going to give credit to
hook even though even if he did mention
that to me okay because
hook never proved it
and there were other people who also
talked about the square of the distance
before newton the only thing newton gave
there is this mathematical
uh
certitude you know where he says it is
true
okay so essentially he proved it through
these theorems that he wrote in his book
okay so just keep in mind that how
things really develop not everyone
who is credited with having discovered
something was the actual discoverer
there was someone who
preceded him who came up with the idea
and this guy just developed it further
and you know fine-tuned it and newton is
credited primarily uh for mathematizing
it and that's more or less uh what he
also said the same thing galileo
mathematized it or proved it you know
kind of put it in rational terms so to
speak okay so that's that's where the
difference is it's not like galileo came
up with these ideas or newton came up
with these ideas these ideas were
already on the books
okay
okay but what uh newton did not discover
was the following
one of the things okay there's a couple
this is the first one he didn't discover
that his force equals mass times
acceleration if we're going to give him
credit for that
uh had to do with push and his uh
gravitational equation force equals uh
gravitational constant g mass 1 mass 2
divided by distance squared
that's pull
okay
and
the other thing here is that these two
are different uh the first formula is
not equal to the second formula which uh
mathematicians today you know they make
them as equal and they say okay mass
times acceleration is equal to
whatever's on the right hand side of
that other on the pull equation not true
okay it's not true
not qualitatively true
what's the difference okay let's find
out that acceleration in in the push
equation in newton's second law that
acceleration includes distance traveled
that's not distance of physics that's
the distance of mathematics and it's
distance traveled displacement
position because position is also a
a pair of uh
numbers okay uh ordered pair
the distance in the pool equation that
is separation between two objects
between mass one and mass two
so the distance in the pull equation is
not the same as the distance traveled in
the push equation
okay that's the first thing we need to
note
and newton never discovered that
and again he did not discover that one
equation or one notion that he put forth
had to do with push and that the other
one had to do with pull
okay is that the only thing he did not
discover no there was something more
fundamental that newton did not discover
okay and
that's this
that you need an object to do physics
you can't do
physics with concepts
okay and this is very important
and here you see he writes to richard
bentley a
fellow who uh looked up to him because
he was such a great mathematician
and he writes to him in 1693 he says
that gravity should act without the
mediation of anything else is to me so
great in absurdity that i believe no man
who has in philosophical matters a
competent faculty of thinking can ever
fall into it
newton could not explain
why
an object is attracted to another
gravitationally why the earth is
attracted to the sun
why the moon is attracted to the earth
he could he could describe and tell you
the relation the mathematical relation
square of the distance
but he cannot tell you why what was
causing gravity and there he essentially
confesses that he has no clue whatsoever
why because he did math and he did not
do physics he was a mathematician not a
physicist okay
and unfortunately
what we have today is a branch that came
out of newton and galileo and went into
mathematical physics and they keep doing
equations they keep doing uh
[Music]
explanation physical interpretations
using concepts
like
mass and force and field
you know instead of using objects
physical objects and here you see uh
from mr galileo what the issue is okay
and he says the following he writes this
he says natural philosophy is written in
that great book whichever is before our
eyes i mean the universe but we cannot
understand it if we do not first learn
the language and grasp the symbols
in which it is written the book is
written in what
mathematical language
okay this is what galileo proposed and
that's what newton liked and that's
where we are today we have this
mathematical language okay and the
symbols are triangles circles and other
geometric geometrical figures absolutely
not the
we do physics with objects not with
triangles okay but this is what these
people had in mind they wanted to prove
things geometrically
mathematically
without whose help it is impossible to
comprehend a single word of it without
which one wanders in vain through a dark
labyrinth
we're still uh wondering through a dark
labyrinth why because these people think
that it's a question of using math and
math has nothing to do with science
neither do experiments you can do all
the experiments you want in your lab you
can do all the
math you want you can calculate whatever
you want that doesn't mean you're going
to be able to explain how mother nature
does the mechanism
that's where the problem is and today we
have a lot of math
and a lot of equations a lot of
measurements what don't we have we don't
have an explanation from these people on
how the universe works which is what the
ordinary person out there thinks is
physics and wants to
what's the mathematician to explain to
him people want to know why this this
pencil my famous experiment okay why
this pencil falls to the floor and not
to the sky
why does it always fall downwards you
know let me do it again repeatable you
know two there he goes
let go of it falls always to the to the
floor why what causes it to fall
downwards not upwards
and they can tell you how fast it goes
you know you have newton's equation you
have uh the gravitational constant you
have the the calculation of the gravity
here on earth all the stuff we have
those are descriptions mathematical
descriptions we still don't have an idea
that mathematicians don't have an idea
what causes this pencil to fall always
to the ground all they have is
description mathematical descriptions
and there you see mathematics is the
language in which god has written the
universe
no absolutely not
the way mother nature god uh the devil
all these fellows right father universe
the way they run the universe is with
objects
with physical objects some of them we
cannot see or touch others we can see
your touch
okay
and touch
uh but so we cannot and that's what
these people never figured out you can't
do an experiment to figure out gravity
yeah
you can't do an experiment to figure out
gravity because
there's nothing to see and nothing to
touch
so you can go to the lab and do all the
experiments you want on gravity
that doesn't mean you're going to come
up with the explanation you're going to
come up with a description a
mathematical description of how fast or
what the acceleration is you can get all
that stuff but what you will never be
able to figure out through math or
through experiments
is how mother nature does that trick
for that you have to make assumptions
some people make assumptions that there
are particles pushing the pencil
downwards other people say well you
remove the air between the pencil and
the floor you know when you remove that
well then there's a push force again
that pushes them together maybe the
earth upwards or the pencil downwards or
maybe it's waves pushing the uh
pencil downwards or maybe it's ropes
pulling it from the you know from the
ground
those are assumptions you have to make
an assumption in order to give a
physical interpretation okay
and math cannot help you at all for that
at all okay all you have with math is
descriptions
okay here's a fellow his name is kevin
brown and he has the math pages and he
tells you essentially what the issues
were in the 17th century and where we
are today he does a pretty good summary
so please bear with me and you know
you'll learn something from this follow
okay he says the finale he says renee
descartes proposed a mechanistic
approach to physics
okay
all casual influence is transmitted by
direct contact between material entities
renee
thought that
you needed physical objects to produce
interaction
gravity
right like aristotle he rejected the
idea of vacuum
rene did not believe in the vacuum okay
we disagree there but okay this is his
assumption he did not believe that there
is
nothing out there it's all something
okay the ether
uh believing that there can be no space
without substance
okay this is rene descartes notion
galileo
the cause of the acceleration of natural
motion and and this is from galileo
these these items he writes this he says
this is what people today think and
maybe it's premature to
think of that we can figure out how
mother nature does these things and he
says he summarizes he said this is what
the theorists of today think
this in galileo's time we're talking
about 1630s 1640s okay it says some
explaining it by attraction to the
center
by whatever okay because again
you're not explaining all you're doing
is
describing if you if you cannot tell me
what's pulling it to the center or
pushing it to the center you have not
given me an explanation so he's wrong
and saying explaining it as that he can
say yeah we notice that everything's
false to the center of of the earth but
we don't know why
so he doesn't have an explanation he's
got a description and people confuse
those two he says others to repulsion
between the very small parts of the body
okay these were different theories going
around in those days
galileo summarizes those and while still
others attribute to
it to a certain stress in the
surrounding medium which closes in
behind the falling body and drives it
from one of its positions to another
okay so we have this push
gravity
that's what uh all these people were
essentially suggesting push gravity some
people have resuscitated push gravity
these days one fall was uh
had a
long discussion with mr van flandern tom
van plander died a few years ago and he
was a push gravity guy
okay um and this uh
follow with kevin brown he continues he
says
he talks about newton here he says every
two particles of matter are compelled
toward each other with a force directly
proportional to their masses and
inversely as the square of the distance
between them this universal gravitation
was apparently contrary to the
mechanistic precepts of the descartes
because it implied that widely separated
bodies exert forces on each other
directly without explicit reference to
any intervening substance okay so this
was the issue was there a substance was
there a material thing
between two objects being attracted
gravitationally
newton disavowed the notion of direct
action at a distance because he could
not what see or touch what was between
two objects okay especially two
celestial objects
newton's overall approach was that
nature consists of atoms moving
according to abstract mathematical laws
in an empty void
that's a mathematical description not a
explanation what was newton a
mathematician he gave us descriptions he
did not give us explanation
and gravity might be a primary attribute
of matter with no material intervening
mechanism that was his notion in other
words the physical explanation he had no
clue about he only had a mathematical
description
okay
well uh we continue here with uh
this follows
analysis math pages
and here are the other people who more
or less try to bring them together
newton with uh descartes here we have
huggins uh leibniz and bernoulli and
they sought some way of reconciling
newtonian gravity with a mechanical
philosophy of descartes
they sought an explanation of universal
gravitation in terms of direct contact
between what material entities because
they said how how does mother nature do
this we need we need to have attraction
between two objects there's got to be
some material um
entity that brings them together there
can't be any action at a distance
without some intervening object that's
what they were saying and they tried to
do this but they couldn't see or touch
whatever was between the objects so it's
a tendency for bodies to be drawn
together is inherently problematic in
the context of cartesian physics because
contact forces are by definition
directed outward from the surfaces of
bodies
even if we hypothesize bodies with hooks
or other interconnecting shapes we must
still rely on a force of cohesion to
maintain the shapes of the bodies so we
haven't avoided the need for a primitive
force of attraction
this shows that purely material
mechanisms
in the sense of descartes are inherently
inadequate to to fully account for the
phenomena of experience meaning
primarily gravity
and yeah see this is the issue that we
still have today because they cannot see
because they cannot touch
whatever physical object is between say
the earth and the
sun or between the moon and the earth
they say there's nothing there because
an object is that which you can see or
touch
and no you're not going to be able to
see or touch the mediators mother nature
uses to do light gravity or magnetism
she made them invisible she made them
intangible we're not going to elucidate
them we're not going to reach
an understanding of them through
equations we're going to reach them only
by you know taking a couple beers
and visualizing proposing making
assumptions
that's the only way you're going to
figure this out okay so you know all
these experiments all these people run
are worthless to tell us how mother
nature runs her shop they're not going
to be able to figure out what's in that
invisible
invisible intangible world of hers okay
okay so um this is essentially what we
have here this was his ending in in the
math pages kevin brown says nevertheless
there were many attempts to give a
mechanistic account of gravity in terms
of contact interactions between what
material bodies
you want to have a mechanistic uh
interpretation because otherwise you're
not doing physics that's the issue
these attempts tacitly rely on
unexplained primitive attractive forces
to maintain the shapes and
configurations of those bodies these
attempts usually took inertia for
granted as a prime as a primitive
attribute of matter they started
including this inertia
you know mass concepts mathematical
concepts that's when they invented these
and started working with these concepts
instead of working with objects why
because they couldn't see or touch the
mediators
the same people in other contexts sought
to account for inertia and purely
relational
terms by invoking primitive interactions
between what material objects you have
to fall back on material objects and
these people on the one hand they have
this duality where on the one hand
they would talk about
inertia mass force
concepts maybe energy
and then on the other they try to
simulate them with objects
and you can't put the two together you
either work with objects and say mother
nature does this with objects
or you start working with all these
mathematical concepts and then you know
without noticing you turn them into
physical objects you reify these
abstractions turned into physical
objects and now you say oh the force oh
the energy mass move this way
weight went upwards
so this is where they got into trouble
because they started using all these
concepts and turning them into physical
objects
and they thought that by doing so they
were giving you a physical
interpretation
and today they
they have this duality again they say
we explained it did you really explain
it but we describe it in
science is about describing
so is it about describing or about
explaining
and that's where the problem is these
people don't explain and only when
someone puts them against the wall
and starts pummeling them and they say
well you know we haven't explained it
but that's philosophy anyways because we
don't know what's in that invisible
world anyways
that's their answer okay
okay so what happens uh it turns out
that um
newton's ghost
followed all the way to the 20th century
to mr einstein who tried to figure out
or
found out this principle of equivalence
okay but newton was there right behind
him because newton said hey
you're going to give us a description a
mathematical description how about an
explanation
and you can see here uh what i need does
he einstein goes in there and just does
a description he says the following ah
see if i can get on the other side here
give me a second
it says this is einstein speaking here
okay it says a little reflection will
show that the law of the equality of the
inertial and gravitational mass is
equivalent to the assertion that the
acceleration imparted to a body by a
gravitational field
field is a physical object but see
a field is imparting acceleration okay
listen to the words
to a body by a gravitational field is
independent of the nature of the body
okay
for newton's equation of motion in a
gravitational field written out in full
it is what inertial mass times
acceleration is equal intensity of the
gravitational field times gravitational
mass and he continues
it is only when there is numerical
equality between the inertial and
gravitational mass that the acceleration
is independent of the nature
of the body okay
and yeah einstein never figured out
either like newton didn't that one has
to do with pull force equals mass times
acceleration is push and and
gravitational one is pull
and so they never figured out that one
has to do with push the other one with
pull these are two qualitative
different notions of force first of all
second
as i already mentioned and i'll go with
that in more detail in the future i've
done it in the past but i'm going to do
it one more time and that's the
acceleration
in the in the second law newton's second
law of force equals mass times
acceleration
the distance there is not distance it's
distance traveled its motion
whereas the distance in the
gravitational equation is the true
distance of physics
separation between what two masses two
objects
okay so these are different they're not
the same equation in fact the second one
is not even force it's tension it's
known as tension not force but newton
didn't know that either neither do the
mathematicians
okay so what do we have
how do we explain
einstein's
principle of equivalence under the rope
model it's no it's a no-brainer
it's a no-brainer qualitatively we can
explain it very easily we have one
hydrogen atom it doesn't matter to what
that hydrogen atom belongs it could
belong to a feather it could belong to
an elephant
here i put it as part of an elephant and
here you can see where the two equations
newton's two equations
if we give it to newton right uh fit in
okay here it is in one case you have
pull okay and that atom there is being
pulled by all the ropes that it's
connected to which means to every atom
on earth i didn't draw them all by the
way okay some people say hey you do only
10
10 ropes there no we got gazillions of
ropes tied to that single atom that
belongs to an elephant so it doesn't
matter at that distance at that exact
separation between that atom and the
center of the earth or whatever
it doesn't matter
if that
atom is going outwards being pushed or
being drawn towards the earth
at that distance at that specific
separation from the earth that atom uh
is equal to that the two equations are
equal they're equal wide they're equal
because of what einstein just said you
know for a single um
entity like in this case the uh
the this atom at a given distance it's
got the same number of ropes converging
on it whether it's going outwards or
coming in
that's the principle that's the reason
behind the principle of equivalence
something einstein wasn't able to figure
out why because he did math he did not
do physics none of these people do
physics they all came out of this notion
that galileo said out there that the
language of the universe is math and you
got to do experiments and observe
and to figure out things and it turns
out you know you can do all the
experiments you want you'll never figure
out gravity because there's nothing to
see and nothing to touch you can see the
things that you can see and touch but
you cannot see the things that you can't
see or touch
and so
what are you going to do i mean
here you have the pencil okay
do you see anything there you see
anything here is there anything you can
touch here or here and if you go out and
you say well there's air yeah air but
air is not producing gravity
so there's nothing you can see or touch
and so what experiment you're gonna do
are you gonna take me to the lab and say
i'm gonna show you gravity
let me show you the gravity what are you
going to show me
all you can do is make an assumption and
whatever here is here whatever's here
is invisible and intangible so don't ask
what does it look like
you know where is it or whatever you
can't see you're touching you can only
make an assumption say let us assume
that all atoms from this pencil are
attached to the earth
then you can explain gravity okay now
you can explain why this falls downwards
if not upwards because you don't have
ropes coming from up here you have ropes
coming from down here
very simple okay baby stuff kindergarten
stuff okay
once you
you have uh
an explanation right once you make the
right assumption
okay one fellow asks he says the
following in relation to this he says
what is the rope made of
and uh i thought it was very clear it's
made up two threads
twine threads we're done
i mean i don't know uh
go to the hardware store tomorrow
and ask for a two-strand rope
and you'll find out that that rope is
made of two
strands we're done see how simple it was
what is the rope made up two strands two
threads whatever you want to call them
two wires two cables
whatever you want to call them two
strings
okay very simple another fellow says
okay smart alec let's find out
what is the threat made of
[Laughter]
well he says what are the threads made
of well there are no threads there is a
thread there's a single thread okay
and this red makes up all the ropes and
all the atoms in the universe so this is
the underlying assumption we're saying
there's a single thread in all of uh
space
but what he's asking is an irrational
question
okay it's an irrational question you say
why is it irrational okay let's find out
here we find out why that question what
is the thread made of
we're talking about a single thread okay
why it's an irrational question here it
is it's a rational question why the
thread is an elementary or fundamental
entity
what is an elementary entity it's one
which is not made of parts
okay the thread is made of a single
piece it's the single thread hypothesis
so what happens uh
you take for example uh quantum
mechanics and they have also uh what is
known as an elementary or fundamental
particle and you say what is an
elementary or fundamental particle well
it's a particle that's not made of you
know simpler parts
very simple
and so now the reporter at the end of
the room says
what is it made of
what's an irrational question because by
definition an elementary particle is one
that is not made of anything it's made
of a single piece
and the guy is asking what is a single
piece particle
made of
well it's not made of anything it's made
of a single piece but that's not what
the quantum mechanics answer what the
so-called theorists answer they say
give us more money
and we'll build a collider that has the
you know as big as the orbit of pluto
then we can smash
this
fundamental elementary particle and we
can tell you what it's made of
and then uh so a is made of bees
and so now the reporter comes next year
he said well what are the bees made of
and the guy says give us more money
we'll build the collider as big as the
galaxy
you know and we'll tell you what it will
smash these particle and we'll tell you
what it's made of
and so this is the problem because they
define
the particle as an elementary
fundamental particle and when you ask
them what is it made of the guy says
give me money and i'll tell you that's
how we do it in science in science we
say the thread is made of a single piece
it's not made of parts it's a
fundamental elementary entity the buck
stops there we now say that the thread
is made of threads of particles of this
or this or that thread is made of a
single piece it's a it's the ultimate
entity
that makes up everything else
hopefully
that's that's the rational universe if
you keep saying well is that made of
parts
you know is it made of particles is it
can it be stretched
if you go with that then now you got
opened up a can of worms because now
people are going to say well what is the
particle that makes the thread made of
well let me get you a you know
a collider as big as the universe and
i'll tell you you know it's it's like
that
no
you have to stop somewhere you have to
start with some
foundation the foundation is the thread
is the ultimate hypothesis
period we're done there it doesn't go
beyond that it's an assumption it's an
assumption to be able to explain atoms
and ropes and from there we can explain
light gravity and uh the workings of the
atom etc that's the way it works in
science it's only an irrational uh
people religious folk typically that
they say what is this made of what is
that made of
and it's made of the same you know
once you tell them that a is made of b
they say well what is b made of and what
a c major what a d made of and so on
down line never stops with them
okay and so this this is where the
problem is it's a an irrational line of
uh
questioning and thinking
okay um
so uh let's move on with some of the
questions some people made uh related to
what is it energy and time last time
let's go over those first
one file says
uh regarding time it says you need three
objects holy trinity more or less to
define time
and no the answer is no with two objects
is fine because you could be one of the
objects
okay
so you don't need three objects you can
do it with two
so it's not absolutely necessary to have
three in fact you don't need three okay
so
very quick answer there another fella
says says uh time has changed uh-huh
uh i got some change in my pocket i i
guess time is money yeah
or the interval over which change occurs
change can be instantaneous
well you see these people
never
bother to analyze the language
and that's why they just say things that
are nonsensical and they don't even
realize their contradictions
instantaneous is a single frame in the
in in the movie
that's what is in the universal movie
cross section of time
you get only one frame there and and
that's instantaneous and you cannot have
motion in a single frame of the movie
all you have is location
okay it's like if you stop the whole
universe
you know god moves as magic one
stops the universe
that's uh instantaneous what you see
there which is just everything frozen
for
eternity
okay
and so instantaneous is not the same
thing as uh
change you change is motion so changes
motion instantaneous is a single frame
change requires at least two frames
and time requires two motions but see
this person chases his tail around he
says time is change
no time has not changed because change
is motion and motion time are not
synonyms
okay you need two motions to get time
you need memory and you don't have that
with uh motion
just single two locations of an object
you don't have that with that okay
so yeah see this is the problem when
people do not check their language they
don't even know what they're saying so
they they chase their tails around in
circles all they do is you know use the
same word they think time has changed
changes simult is uh instantaneous you
know they say all these things it's just
nonsensical language
okay uh
fellow says
energy is a change of time
with time defined as a comparison of two
motions okay
and it says you're changing the motion
of two objects relative to each other
okay it then follows that a change in
motion is energy between any two objects
the only criticism i have here is that
energy is a word that's used by the
mathematicians we don't need the word
energy at all
not in science uh it's a it's a word of
religion okay so
that's uh the only thing i wouldn't use
the word energy at all trying to figure
out what energy is you know uh energy is
defined as what capacity
the ability
that's what energy is what is that
that's a concept
how can you transfer the ability that's
the issue so we don't need the word
energy at all because you're just
talking about spirits okay anyone using
the word energy is just introducing
religion into into their theories
okay and here's a fellow says all energy
is motion
[Laughter]
of some kind okay
uh kinetic energy is obvious uh but
potential energy too
okay we have all these
kinetic and potential energy oh spirits
right
uh gravitational potential energy is
something
well if it's something we're talking
about an object a thing in fact he says
that their coulomb potential energy is
another invisible thing
so are these
uh invisible
intangible things
is that what they are or is energy
motion
how can energy be motion and at the same
time be a thing how can it be all a noun
and also a verb
but see these people don't realize they
just say whatever nonsense comes to
their mind and they think they're being
rational no a thing is that which has
shape and motion is two locations of an
object
and either energy is something that has
shape right
that which has shape or it is two
locations of an algae energy cannot be
both god cannot be a thing and a concept
at the same time either god is that
fellow with a magic wand that made the
universe or god is love and intelligence
or whatever
god cannot be both okay so you got to
choose who you pray to and this fellow
wants to pray to both he's got these
dualities in his head uh stuff that you
know he was they they
uh taught him in school he just
memorized this stuff and just
regurgitates him that's all he does
that's the way a lot of these people
work okay here we have another one
this one's even better
uh here you see why these guys are
religious people and they don't belong
inside i don't even know why these
people get into science if they have all
these religious nonsense in their heads
paul says everything in the universe is
energy
now doesn't that sound like god isn't
god everything right yeah that's like uh
energy is everything and therefore
energy is nothing as well because if
everything i guess includes nothing
right
physical atoms are made up of what
vortices
of concepts what is vortices it's a
tornado that's what a word is it's just
uh
something that's twirling
so uh physical objects are made of verbs
okay atoms are made of verbs
vertex uh mathematics is what patterns
of numbers in fact he's telling you
there he says well but you have these
numbers are moving around they're
swirling around and that's what an atom
is uh numbers that are swirling around
maybe it's the fives or sixes you know
they go around
watch out that 10 comes over and hit you
in the head you know
energy is capacity what is that i mean
it's everything it's a vortice it's a
pattern of numbers now it's capacity
you see all these notions this guy has
in his head poor guy you know i mean i
don't know what monastery he went to he
said vacuum energy
so you have vacuum energy okay exists
throughout the entire universe
you have the energy of nothing
vacuum okay and then we have uh
vacuum energy can be experimentally
observed
yeah
i'll let you observe the vacuum all day
long okay and uh come back and tell me
what it looks like okay
my god
these poor people
[Laughter]
it's really funny when you start to
analyze them no i like richard feynman's
uh definition better i've shown that
several times let me show it one more
time let me get this bigger here
okay what did he say it is important to
realize that in physics today we have no
knowledge of what energy is
that's the best definition i found for
energy energy is defined as capacity
it's defined as the ability you know
they have all these definitions for
energy then they transfer it then they
put a number in equation tell you that's
energy they put units for it
joules or whatever
energy the quantitative property
transferred to an object
how do you transfer a property
how do you trans how do you transfer
love to someone else here let me
transfer my love
or my hate i can transfer hate and love
you know whatever
yeah
all these people transfer love and hate
this is my version of energy okay here
it is you heard it here for the first
time this is bill gates version of
energy
here we have it okay we have uh
potential energy one ghost one spirit
there and then uh
we have a kinetic energy and it looks
something like that it's this cloud this
mysterious hazy
fog that's floating out there that's
energy right
and i don't know how you grasp it you
know with your hands so that you can
transfer it
i don't know how they do that in math
but we we can't do it in physics okay so
yeah
uh forget about energy we don't need the
word energy at all okay
now the fellow says
changing subject here says space is bent
especially around me i mean it looks
like
it's
squeezing me like an accordion you know
space is bent against me i guess yeah
but photon think it's still on straight
path
so we have the photon going straight but
space is bent okay so i don't know where
you got that so photon doesn't feel
direction
change equal no force
i hope everybody understood that okay
yeah i can't even answer this poor
fellow because i have no idea what he's
got going through his head okay yeah
okay let's move on fell says
let me get this height bigger
well it says the following he says uh
your definition of motion multiple
locations excluded rotation
i demonstrated that with the triangle
whose location minimum separation from
the cube never changed as it rotated it
is possible for a triangle to rotate
without having multiple separations from
another object
labeling points is absolutely cheating
because i took this little ball you know
and i said look here's a point okay
and uh you can see that it moves and he
didn't like that he said oh you labeled
the point
that's cheating okay you were uh
sneakily splitting the sphere
into pieces
well i think it's the other way around i
think he's cheating he's cheating
himself okay
because whenever you have a rotation
uh you have two whatever it is you have
two two of whatever and we're not
talking about a separate object out
there like you said you know triangle
with respect to a cube or a sphere with
respect to a triangle we're not talking
about that we're talking about rotation
for example of a sphere
we have two situations here one is the
observer and the other one is the sphere
itself
as it observes itself it knows whether
it's spinning or not whether you know
you the observer knows it or not
if this were made of a single piece
how can you tell how can even it tell
that it's rotating
the only way you identify a second point
on its surface like i did the other day
so here's a point now you can tell it's
rotating because now this thing goes
around okay
now you can say it's rotating
if you don't have that how do you know
how do you know this is rotating right
now
how does the sphere know that it's
rotating for example if it's made of a
single piece
unless you unless it
identifies a point on its own surface
and says now i'm rotating
how can you conceptualize rotation
without two
that's the question
okay so no you're cheating not me okay
you're trying to cheat yourself you're
cheating yourself essentially you don't
realize what you're saying
okay
now the fella brings up another issue
says magnetism so the geometry doesn't
fit in this proposal
in another follow seconds that he says
it doesn't match with what bill depicts
well these are trolls
that's all you can say because you know
how you can discover a troll
because they don't tell you what they
did not understand i mean if they say
the geometry doesn't fit this proposal
they have to explain a little more they
can't just say it doesn't fit the
proposal i don't know what they're
talking about
and so
that's just you know uh
spamming it's just trolling all they're
saying is oh it doesn't do it okay
if you don't understand it i can't help
you i need to understand
from you
what uh what you find wrong with it not
just say it doesn't match
in fact what he put in there that that
was what i he got that from me because i
put the magnet in the water okay i
showed them this uh in many videos in
the past
and what you're seeing there
is the opposite that it does depict
uh
the rope model
why because you can see each one of
those iron filings that is approaching
the magnet inside the water okay
those iron filings are coming in one at
a time
what you have to explain is what
attracts them how what physical entity
is drawing those iron filings to the
magnet
you understand the question let me
repeat it because they haven't
understood yet you have to explain
what physical object
came in contact with the iron filing and
pulled it
towards the magnet
that's what you got to explain okay
and the only way you can explain that is
with something that is moving in that
area in fact james maxwell said that in
that region
magnetic field
there is matter in emotion
matter in motion there's some exotic
matter he said that is moving in there i
don't know what it is i can't see it i
can't touch it i don't know i have no
idea but there is matter in motion
and that's what you're seeing here
matter in motion so
before you can say that it doesn't meet
the proposal or it doesn't depict it you
got to first explain what it is that you
don't understand and second
please propose what physical entity is
drawing one iron filing at a time
towards the magnet
is it particles
if it is particles tell me what is
what is pushing the particles that push
the
iron filing in that direction are the
particles coming from outer space from
inside the water
if it's waves
what is moving what what is it show me a
wave you know first of all no it says
thing as a way
you know is it ether is it uh
avortus
vortix what is it
so you gotta explain what physical
object
is coming in concept with content
context
uh in in
in contact with the art valley that's
what you gotta explain if you can't
explain that you got nothing to say okay
so yeah don't just say oh it it doesn't
depict because you haven't explained it
you haven't justified what what you
don't understand first you gotta explain
a little more than that not just a
one-liner okay another follow says uh
electromagnetic rope is self-torque
okay i'm not sure what that means really
but after releasing this torque how it
generates again
and here's his main point he says i mean
there must be resistance in the rope
that stopped the torque in other words
he thinks that the torque is a one-way
mechanism that's the problem here
he thinks that torque comes out of you
know the the rope is connected to two
atoms let me get this out for a second
maybe i can show it
here simulate it with my hands okay
here we have
my famous rope okay and we have two
atoms my fists okay
and so this guy thinks that this atom
expands and contracts torques the rope
and
the the signal moves along the rope all
the way to the other side
what's really happening is both atoms
are torquing simultaneously and the
whole rope is moving
all we're changing really is the link
lengths
but the whole rope is moving at all
times it's not like the signal goes one
way and the other atoms waiting there
you know saying okay when will that
signal arrive
that's not the way it works the whole
rope is torquing at the same time
from the atom in the
andromeda galaxy all the way to here
the rope never stops torquing okay
rope always torques
okay another fella says
a pull mechanism can be accomplished
with particles by convergence the sage
had the the idea
[Laughter]
so there are two possibilities one is
you know i have uh my dear fellow
casimir they're throwing stones at the
donkey and attracting it is that how
pull works by throwing stones at it
well the fella suggests not that one but
the one at the bottom he says if you
remove the particles from
between two objects the particles on the
outside push them together that was
essentially the sages uh
which was not his theory okay again um
uh
theory he said uh it's a shadow
uh gravity so to speak okay
but first we got to show that uh le sage
was not the first guy to come up with
that either i mean we have all these
plagiarizers out there here okay so
let's get that straight first this is la
says theory of gravity he wrote it to
his father in 1747 he wrote him oh i
discovered it that was in 1747 he makes
his first draft in 1748 he didn't
publish that one he published it in 1756
and in 1758 he makes the second
publication of his so-called theory
turns out that before he published we
had this other fellow a german guy
reddicker and he had already published
it in 1751 before he before the sage
published it
then we had this fellow cramer and
he wrote an informal paper in 1731
in which he quoted
or essentially regurgitated fascio's uh
theory of 1689.
okay so
faggio was the first guy to propose that
he proposed it to neutron newton he was
a friend of newton's he proposed this um
shadow
theory of gravity and uh kramer caught a
wind of it and he was lesade's teacher
and so the sage later on says oh it's my
theory and he published today it's known
as the
theory of gravity so the first thing you
got to get right is that lessage theory
of gravity is not let's say series of
gravity it's the fascio
theory of gravity but then uh it turns
out fascio also got his ideas from
lucretius uh who lived uh in uh right
before the christian era
and uh he wrote it in his uh uh
in in a long poem that he wrote about uh
different things of how nature works
okay
so um
yeah again sometimes you gotta look up
and find out who came up with the theory
first okay who came up with these ideas
first but uh yeah
this has the um
the notion that you have the shadow
gravity
that you remove particles from
here you have a pencil and i let go of
it how did i remove particles from here
so that the particles from above push it
downwards
what sense does that make
i mean it had to be uh
you know people with mental problems
that still insist on the particle theory
on particle theories in general how does
a individual particle push or pull on
another one here you have two particles
okay one's over here the other one's
over here how does it pull or push
that's all you got to explain how does
one
particle pull or push on another
particle
and of course the way the mathematicians
did you know what they did is
invent concepts such as force mass
gravity and they say oh it's it pulls it
through gravity
oh it applied a force
it did it through inertia
it's all that energy it threw at it it's
mass
all those are concepts
you can't explain physically how this
one affects this one
unless you have a physical object in
between them in this case i know if you
see that there's a little string now you
can explain you know at least pull
and of course when they're in touch with
each other you can explain push
otherwise you cannot explain it you need
physical objects you need physical
mediators in that invisible world of
mother natures okay
okay two more issues one file says
if action equal reaction is a universal
uh it is a universal law there cannot be
a big bang right
yeah big bang uh how do you create space
which is what big bang is supposedly
created
you know there was this explosion
13.8 14 billion years ago
and it created not only matter we can
all understand more or less matter how
did it create nothing
how do you create nothing the space out
there
you know we can we can create i create
nothing all the time
it's easy to create nothing i mean you
know i think the
we didn't need the big bang to create
nothing
how did god create nothing
what was god before he created nothing i
mean
well
did he have shape
because the only way i can conceptualize
god with shape is if he's within space
nothing vacuum
but if not even vacuum exists i don't
know what surrounds god i don't know
what kind of he's infinite he's an
infinite block of something
my god
okay uh phil says
did anyone else see those news stories
about ropes found around the earth
[Laughter]
well uh all i can tell you if if uh if
we found ropes around the earth they
can't be the ropes the electromagnetic
ropes
because the ropes cannot be seen or
touched
anyone who's trying to see touch ropes
is out of his mind okay you can't see or
touch the electromagnetic ropes they are
assumptions
uh that you need in order to explain a
a mechanism and the mechanism we're
trying to explain are things we cannot
see or touch such as gravity
magnetism the workings of the atom light
etc
so if you're going to explain intangible
invisible mechanisms don't ask how can i
see them how can i touch them
you're you're asking for proof first of
all which is outside the bounds of
science and then you're wasting your
time because you can't see or touch the
mediators mother nature uses
to do her daily work
with that i'll see you on sunday we'll
see you there
bye-bye